All right.
For the first one, I'm going to put 3/4 where I see a smiley face. Then, I have
addition and then, I have 1/12 for the diamond. When adding fractions, I need to
get a common denominator. So, I'm going to multiply this first one by 3/3, so, I
get 9/12 + 1/12, 9/12 + 1/12 = 10/12. I can reduce this fraction by dividing by
2. And I get 5/6. For this next one, I'm going to replace this smiley face with
3/4, I have subtraction, and then the diamond is 1/12. Again, I need to convert
to a common denominator. Well, I know 3/4 is really 9/12 from the problem
before. So, I have 9/12 minus 1/12. And, when I subtract 9/12 minus 1/12 is
8/12. And, the equivalent fraction for 8/12 is 2/3. I divided 8 by 4, and 12 by
4, and I got two-thirds. Here, I replace the smiley face with 3/4, I had
multiplication, and then the diamond is 1/12. I can reduce common factors in the
numerator, and in the denominator, I divide 3 by 3 and I get 1, I divide 12 by 3
and I get 4. When I multiply my fractions across, 1 times 1 is 1, 4 times 4 is
16. And for this last one, I have 3/4 divided by 1/12. Remember, dividing by a
number is the same thing as multiplying by its reciporical. So I have 3/4 times
12/1. I can reduce a common factor of 4, since it appears in the numerator, and
in the denominator. 12 divided by 4 is 3. And 4 divided by 4 is 1. 3 times 3 is
9. 1 times 1 is 1. So I have 9 divided by 1, or 9. Nice work on that quiz.